[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi tu as pris les rideaux de ta
mère pour faire une veste
possible elle est très bien sa veste ah
merci merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis dans la
propositions
c'est quoi le pack non c'est pas moi le
patron mais la veste elle est très bien
merci Dylan un petit bruit de train pour
m'encourager super merci beaucoup
[Rires]
tu fais quoi
quelle équipe
puisque vous m'avez taillé en arrivant
sur le plateau et bien alors je vais
commencer par vous d'ailleurs sur une
échelle de 1 à 10 au niveau de la
confiance en vous en êtes où en ce
moment oui
1 2 3000
Virginie vous qui venait de venir est-ce
que vous trouvez que j'ai confiance en
moi
[Applaudissements]
sur 10
quoi je suis à deux je suis du numérique
c'est vrai que vous êtes très humble
Cyril et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on
a nommé cette séquence le modèle de la
semaine
le
modèle j'ai l'impression que je suis mal
coiffé
ça m'énerve ça me nique l'émission
[Rires]
[Musique]
je sais que je suis beau gosse
tu sais je suis vraiment très content de
mon physique
4 oh mon physique
je rigole
[Applaudissements]
pas
en plus j'aime bien chauffer Kelly
ça veut dire vraiment elle est pas du
tout dans le délire de la
darka et donc j'aime bien aller venir
les faire chier là-bas et je voudrais
vous faire chier à la pub là
vous pensez quoi sincèrement honnêtement
je vous dis ce que je dis avoir la
vérité
je comprends que des millions de gens
qui veulent me regarder tous les jours
je rigole vraiment franchement je me
regarder rarement alors franchement vous
avez un petit miroir sur le plateau là
direct même sur le plateau
mais c'est vrai quand je me regarde
pourquoi tu m'as dit que vous voyez
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que je me dirais
qu'est-ce que je me dis vas-y dis ce que
vous pensez votre valdah je suis de
mieux en mieux non non vous savez moi
alors le physique pour moi le physique
pour moi ça compte si peu
oh je vous laisse avec quand je me
revois dans la glace c'est à quoi je
pense je me dis l'important c'est ce que
j'ai ici dans le cœur
[Applaudissements]
de notre gueule
vous considérez être le plus bel
animateur bah oui franchement oui
chacun va se trouver chacun va se
trouver beau voilà on va pas dire ouais
je suis moche il va toujours se mettre
en valeur moi je suis animateur c'est
chacun va dire ça parce que voilà moi je
suis le meilleur animateur imitateur du
sifflet du train je vais pas lui dire
contraire
[Rires]
tu te dis pas je suis le meilleur
imitateur du sifflet du train non moi je
me regarde pas dans la glace
vous trouvez plus beau Brad Pitt
franchement
il y en qui préfèrent en Brad Pitt il y
en a qui préféreront
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il est blond c'est tout alors il est
bleu
pour que je redescende c'est lui ah lui
il me sauve il vient dans ma loge tous
les soirs je vous jure c'est vrai une
voiture
tous les soirs il s'assoit après
l'émission pendant 10 minutes sur mon
fauteuil dire que tu pourrais pécho 95%
des femmes de la planète
je vous jure qu'il m'a dit ça c'est pour
vous gratter les bagnoles aujourd'hui
quelle femme tu ne pourrais pas séduire
tu t'es déjà posé cette question là
toi aujourd'hui
quelle femme
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si elle va dîner si elle va dîner
qu'elle passe une soirée ou de ou une
après-midi avec lui c'est très compliqué
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de femmes il
met beaucoup de trucs
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable
jamais pas les amis pas les amis pour la
famille des souvenirs franchement on
arrive pas les amis il faut la famille
pas plus de 80 ans
une mesure à plus de 80 ans Cyril
puisque vous vous me prenez jamais de
râteau sachez que
vous avez beaucoup de chance non non
comparé à un autre qui s'appelle
Jean-Michel maire qui lui en a eu un peu
moins cette semaine Jean-Michel
franchement Jean-Michel pour le coup est
vraiment
lui aussi sauf qu'il s'est pris un
énorme râteau sur ce plateau alors vous
allez voir dans un instant qui lui
amènera tôt mais le plus important ce
n'est pas ça le plus important c'est
l'excuse qui lui a été donné on a tous
connu ces petits moments de faiblesse
une fille qui nous plante parce que je
sais pas elle est un peu trop de travail
ou elle s'est cassé le doigt de pied ou
peu importe et bien là l'excuse est
au-delà de l'imaginable j'adore c'est le
râteau de la semaine j'adore
le râteau de la semaine
c'est un sniper
une pizza à côté pizza je peux pas j'ai
des dents en résine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je vais vous donner un truc
ah voilà il faut toujours être lucide
c'est-à-dire Raymond j'ai la chance de
passer voilà beaucoup de temps avec lui
il a une lucidité incroyable
il est arrivé lors d'une soirée il m'a
dit tu sais j'ai dit sur deux yeux
donc je peux te dire je vois très bien
ce qui se passe attention misez toujours
sur la bonne personne je pense que vous
avez plus de chance avec Camille qu'avec
Sophie comme ça
Sofia des dents en résine
[Applaudissements]
donc un moment il faut dis-lui
avec Amélie comme ça bien sûr et tout de
suite après tu l'attaques elle c'est
mauvais tu dis bien sûr il est en train
de China Amélie il vient il propose une
pizza non mais il se croit où tu t'es
fait bâcher c'est le technicien qui
parle
ça arrive même aux meilleurs séries on
passe maintenant oh je vais juste de la
semaine
j'ai vu je ne dirai pas
je dirais quand même
ah non c'est mort maintenant ce dossier
en tête je peux pas passer une chose
donc on passe de la semaine
vous me comprenez rien ce qui vous dit
lorsque vous êtes pourtant à quelques
mètres alors on se dit que lorsqu'on est
à quelques millimètres peut-être on
comprend mais en fait pas du tout
Valérian a fait les frais cette semaine
c'est
[Musique]
de la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
j'arrive à peu près à lire sur tes
lèvres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas la folie
qui m'a envoyé
comment il a aucune chance oui super
[Rires]
je sais pas si vous vous en souvenez en
tout cas pour ceux qui étaient pas là la
semaine dernière Kelly a eu un petit
moment d'absence on regarde si chacun va
dire la même chose la Chine a souffert
il y a un an
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
compris la semaine
le on n'a pas compris de la semaine
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'elle avait un torticolis de
fou plus la dent plus le torticolis
en fait un truc de comment s'appelle
[Rires]
le bail c'est que j'ai avec les
problèmes de vue j'ai l'autisme mais en
fait ça vient d'un syndrome de mutation
génétique et j'ai 8 ans de sagesse comme
les enlever j'ai eu trop mal je suis
venu une semaine sur votre émission
après quoi en même temps oui en même
temps
la preuve une semaine après j'étais sur
votre plateau
à la place non bah non les enfants
tu peux lui dire qu'il est con
j'allais dire il faut écouter les dents
de sagesse ça s'enlève mais ça se remet
pas merci
par contre la connerie ça reste hein
c'est pas les dents de lait c'est pas
les Anglais c'est les dents de sagesse
c'est les dents qui sont au fond
reste dans ton domaine lequel la glande
on est sur mon compte un peu serré non
non
c'est pas moi qui prends cette décision
moi son avis sur les autres personnes
c'est pas moi qui vais dire lui il est
méchant lui il est gentil ok donc merci
merci
non tu dois te méfier je te dis
alors à votre avis que fait Cyril
pendant les pubs alors tout le monde se
pose la question peut-être vous à la
maison peut-être vous dites qu'il dit
ces interviews à venir ou qu'il répond à
deux trois textos qui parlent à des
chroniqueurs boulot quoi
il essaie de nous gratter de l'oseille à
nous employé pauvre employé c'est comme
ça TOI oui il essaie de l'ouvrir
j'ai peur de l'oseille c'est l'inverse
moi
tout ce qu'il dit mais si c'est le
Picsou de la semaine je vais la preuve
le Picsou de la semaine
vas-y celui qui m'a vu tu me dis balles
allez 8 minutes les amis on va revenir
dans une minute tu vas te casser un
genou voilà tu vas 10 balles non mais
merde alors les jeux Cyril c'est que
quand on perd contre vous on vous donne
l'argent mais quand on gagne on vous
donne l'argent quand même mais c'est
quoi ça
ah ça a tapé là ça fait
tu as déjà vu dans un terrain de foot
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu as vu ça il a vu ça où lui pourquoi
ne t'inquiète pas
dans les terrains de foot ouais mais tu
es mauvais perdant tu es mauvais joueur
[Applaudissements]
on doit de l'argent mais tu gagnes on
doit aussi de l'argent en fait
[Rires]
certains chroniqueurs sont un peu trop à
l'aise sur ce plateau Cyril vous me
direz pas le contraire oui et cela mais
il se lâche dans tous les sens du terme
encore c'est Castaldi alors on croirait
comme ça première impression que c'est
Castaldi mais en fait non il y a un
autre chroniqueur ou une autre
chroniqueuse qui a des gaz en ce moment
ce plateau oui méfiez-vous les
apparences c'est le flatuler de la
semaine
[Musique]
dernière emploi
[Applaudissements]
alors une odeur particulière c'est
dégueulasse sur plateau vous l'avez vu
la tête de Géraldine et du coup ça en
devient l'info pendant la pluie
est-ce qu'il est bien avec vous Cyril
c'est que lorsqu'on vous confie un truc
vous savez rester discret ah non mais
non mais Jean-Marie il arrête pas de
tête
ça va ici
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
merci en tout cas très beau témoignage
de Raymond et géralisme merci à vous
c'est pas arrivé jusqu'à Daniel non non
on a vérifié c'est bien Jean-Marie dans
TPMP
je vous le dis moi ce que je faisais à
parce que voilà je vais m'arrête de le
faire en quatre voilà j'avais déjà pété
98 pour la parce que la France est
championne du monde
il faut dire cette phrase il faut dire
c'est la première fois que ça m'arrive
même si c'est vrai
si vous êtes avec une fois je me
rappelle un jour en classe il y a un mec
il a pété tout le monde a entendu mais
quand tu es en classe tu es à 30 dans la
classe c'est relou je te fais tout petit
le mec s'appelait Stéphane Paulin
sur la vie de ma mère s'appelait
Stéphane Polin le gars je sais pas s'il
nous regarde il attaque mais vraiment un
truc de ouf en plein contrôle et sur moi
il a fait
est-ce que tais-toi tu dis mais tais-toi
du coup j'ai dit moi je j'arrête le
contrôle je ne travaille pas dans ces
conditions
[Rires]
on annule le contrôle
vis de procédure Alain tu es bien avec
nous très bien tu peux rester tu
connaissais Bernard Montiel je suis venu
l'émission des animaux c'est ça des
animaux vidéo gags
c'est qui ton préféré de tous
[Rires]
[Musique]
vous êtes à côté de Bernard Montiel et
bien on va passer à l'employé de la
semaine pourquoi parce que dans TPMP ça
débat souvent vous le savez et il y a
certains chroniqueurs qui flippent
peut-être de perdre leur passe puisque
c'est la fin de la saison et du coup
qu'est-ce qu'ils font pendant les débats
et bien ils orientent leur position
n'ont pas en fonction du vent comme ils
disent mais en fonction de ce que pense
Baba en gros c'est la candidature c'est
l'employé de la semaine dernière
l'employé de la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine
[Applaudissements]
exactement je vais donner je vais donner
beaucoup de nouvelles émissions
il va s'en mettre plein les fouilles ça
va mon lit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je finis par mon extrait préféré de la
semaine c'est quoi alors
j'ai une
question de votre famille votre
entourage ou des chroniqueurs vous
parlent ou de vos équipes mais que vous
n'en avez rien à carrer qu'est-ce que
vous faites quel est votre technique je
vous donne la réponse il cherche une
issue de secours
c'est le sortez-moi de la semaine
le sortez-moi de là de la semaine
[Musique]
un jour
rapidement
alors voilà une discussion entre
professionnel des reptiles et des
rongeurs et plus la conversation avance
plus vous êtes passionné Cyril
le rongeur en fait s'attaque
et comme dans ma salive dérangeurs il y
a une espèce d'anesthésiant
même pas compte qu'il serait rangé
on s'intéresse en France
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avec plaisir avec plaisir je suis Cyril
ça veut
dire
quoi
dans une minute
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]